welcome to this live stream with me Sean
Connell all about how to build your
influence with YouTube online business
and social media we're gonna be taking
your questions if you're watching on the
replay there's bound to be a nugget or
two that you can apply to get an edge
right now pivot your plan and grow your
business you know it's a crazy time that
we're living with in the world right now
and what is really nuts is that I just
read this article and it revealed this
that zoom is now worth more than all of
the airline companies the biggest ones
the seven biggest airline companies
combined zoom is coming in at forty
eight billion dollars and yet the
Airlines American Airlines luffa Sinisa
you know United I don't even what I just
said Delta Southwest are worth forty six
obviously because of the lockdown
because of the pandemic things have been
massively disrupted but what does that
tell me it tells me that YouTube online
video social media online business is
absolutely what all of us need to be
doing right now to pivot and whether or
not you have a business that you need to
pivot online whether you're thinking
about starting a business what a time I
mean it seems like a crazy time but a
lot of the biggest fortune 500 companies
were started during a recession because
what do entrepreneurs do they solve
problems and guess what the world has a
lot of problems right now so we are here
to help and solve those problems that's
what this stream is all about hit the
like button and I'm excited to take your
questions and so if you have a question
drop like for question marks before or
after it and I would love to answer your
questions in a bit
maybe we'll bring some people on as well
to talk a little bit about come on life
business social media YouTube what have
you been struggling with what is your
perspective right now in terms of your
challenges
you need help with coming up with an
idea do you need help scaling do you
need help monetizing and then shout out
if you haven't heard there's only a few
hours left to watch my most recent free
masterclass about how I use one simple
YouTube strategy to turn one hundred and
thirty dollars into over thirteen
thousand dollars don't miss that idea to
income dot tips is where you can watch
that that is kind of a weird URL not
calm idea to income dot tips and you can
check that out for free but super
limited where I break down some cool
case studies but if you got a question
throw up multiple question marks and
would love to answer and help we got
Sarah's question I did uber suggestions
on the content that I wanted how can I
help with that let me know and as we get
deeper into that question I hope y'all
are using ubersuggest for keyword
research so ubersuggest is a cool way to
verify an idea to get some insights so
you know let's imagine you were in like
ketogenic so I'm gonna type in Quito now
watch this
if you had a fitness channel you could
drill down and get some cool ideas on
maybe what you should go after in search
we're gonna go to keyword ideas on the
left here and here's one of my favorite
parts about this tool because you can
jump in here and go to like questions is
Quito bad how keto works
why keto diet is bad how keto diet works
are keto diets safe and these are
actually of course YouTube videos you
should be making one keyword one video
or one keyword phrase one video and
you're you're verifying interest by
seeing the search volume over here some
people in the industry think that like
keyword research doesn't matter and it
matter anymore and that's not true it's
laughable in fact because what you're
doing is you're reverse engineering
researching before your press record and
so definitely use ubersuggest and let me
know what is one
of how do you do your keyword research
if you do we're gonna smash some
questions so gently touch the like
button okay would it be important to
establish a presence first in order to
start selling online courses David asks
you know putts potentially yes but not
not necessarily I'll tell you this think
if ik which is a online course brand I
talked to them at a conference called
social media marketing world it really
told me their most successful course
sellers are all YouTube creators listen
to this the reason why and this is think
if ik they're just another platform to
host your course courses and do
different things and different platforms
different prices but the reason why is
because 65% of people go to YouTube
looking to answer a specific question so
David maybe somebody doesn't know you
yet but they know they have a problem so
if you're answering specific questions
on YouTube somebody finds your YouTube
video find some free information and
some free value and then if you have an
online course they could go to the next
level and learn more about that from you
make sense so do you need to establish
your presence first not necessarily you
know one thing that's interesting my
friends that you could look up is go to
you to me and type in your topic David
follow up with me what's your topic and
what's your niche but like let's say you
teach guitar and maybe that's even a
little too obvious but you can see other
people having courses or maybe to like
lends itself to learning but like let's
literally say you teach math you know
what I mean so I've become an algebra
master alright let's check this out
let's do the math and some research on
here of like what this person's making
with this online course at you know
$14.99 which is the discounted price
this course is normally 114 there's
thirty five thousand six hundred and
five students enrolled so we're in at
times this multiplied it by thirty five
thousand six hundred and five at that
price and and you know so far Krista's
made five hundred and thirty three
thousand seven hundred and eighteen
dollars so that'll make you fall out of
your chair on a Friday or whenever
you're watching this let me know we were
watching from and when you're watching
this if you're catching the replay hit
the like button and so here's the
question you start making YouTube videos
answering questions about algebra
showing up in search and then you're
like hey you want to go check out my
course on udemy or kajabi is what we use
and Italy it lends itself like straight
to people that are already in the mode
of learning so there you go someone
asked missed the question but oh yeah
Dimitri what streaming software are we
using for life so I use a lot of
different software's let me drop a link
on you called think media tools comm and
so if anybody's curious this is our tool
guide and you can check out we have our
video editing tools I'm streaming right
now in stream yard which is so easy to
use like I can pop it up like this and
get a lot of different dynamics to it so
I'll drop a link to that over to on the
tool page as well as on YouTube wherever
you're watching this but we got South
Africa in the house we got Nashville in
the house shout out for the QA today we
got Canada here awesome and people from
all over the place and let's hit up some
more questions um our business cards
still relevant no next question says uh
I'd like to collect business cards
meaning at an event I get a pile of
business cards I have them here I've
always wanted to follow up I've done
nothing with them I've wrapped them in
rubber bands so I just feel like a lot
of times that they just don't make it to
their their ideal destination when we go
to an event like CES and NAB when
there's not a lock down as soon as we
get the business card we take a picture
of it and pretty much trash the business
card so I think digital business cards
are really what it is and we put those
in a drop box for times when we even
lost the business cards so we can follow
up with our contacts after
for business for influencer marketing
you know product reviews or whatever but
here's the bigger thing when networking
and networking to get a bad rap like we
all need a network it's about building
relationships it's about serving people
it's about meeting people if I want to
have a relationship with anybody I just
gotta take the full ownership on me so
here's what I mean it's like handing a
business card and hoping something will
happen
I don't believe does anything let me
know what your thoughts are to in the
community drop a comment about your
thoughts our business cards still
relevant I'd love to pass a question off
to you but I like to think hey let's
connect give me your number or what's
your Instagram I'm gonna DM you right
now or what's your LinkedIn let me add
you right now I'm sending you a message
right now and then I'm gonna usually
open up a little note on my phone a
little note collection and put all the
people I want to follow up with I want
to follow up with this brand and email
them I want to make sure I follow up
with that person and see if we can
collab I want to follow up with that
person because we had a vibe maybe we
could just jump on a zoom call and see
if there's any synergy I'm gonna follow
up with that person and see if there can
be any business development
opportunities so the business card is
kind of a touch point but I think
there's new-school ways to do it like
that what is your favorite 4k camera for
YouTube oh I just I'm under NDA about a
new camera that the information already
leaked online about and so you could
probably find it but I can't tell you
and I can't say yes or no about it the
embargo ends in a few days so we got
some new content coming out on thick
media my current favorite 4k camera is
the Sony a7 three is our go-to for our
all-around favorite content creation
tool I think the a 6400 or a 6600 is is
pretty all-time if you haven't heard
about kit comm it's one of my favorite
places to summarize my gear kits and so
you can see our favorite kits here the a
6600 kit that's definitely super
relevant unlimited record time we've
been using this for podcasting video
podcasting because of unlimited record
time
and you know a lot of these DSLRs and
mirrorless cameras have a 30 minute
record limit including the a7 3 but from
a picture standpoint we love the a7 3
that's our setup right here to think
media 4k camera kit by the way when you
go to think to kit go for it / Sean
kennel you can see videos embedded and
you can see all the kit below so this
this a step 7 3 is still our go-to we
got Omar in the video what a poem our
shout out if you are a normo marfan and
I would then say I'm also super pumped
about the m6 mark 2 it happens to be
sitting right next to me so this was
canons best step forward into affordable
4k uncropped 4k flip up screen you need
a little relocation plate to put the mic
off to the side but what a sexy little
cameraman oh you could just Mike about
to like make out with the camera so this
is this is a fire setup I was actually
submitting some footage to CNBC for a
little featurette or something I'm gonna
be in and I was kind of documenting my
like my day or something and so this was
the setup I use this is a cool vlog
wide-angle lens on there and that's the
m6 mark 2 and so uh check that out
problem with watch hours and views
thinking it might be my thumbnails so
Adam could be um but usually on YouTube
it's a mix of a little bit of everything
you know
so think about think about it in terms
of like a progression even like a funnel
just in terms of okay the wide funnel is
what am I gonna watch on youtube today
then the next thought is look at these
titles and these thumbnails is that
interesting then the next thing they
have to do is click and then once they
click then is the first 10 seconds of
the video you gotta hook they attention
then and if the beginning of the video
does not grab attention fast
do not ever start a video with an intro
like a bumper like video starts
and done enough I'll be there for you
Cheech
you know friends and like you got to
start with a hook you got to grab
attention right up front so they they
gotta like be on YouTube click a title
and a thumbnail be hooked in the
beginning and then you got to keep their
attention through the through the video
to keep the watch time so we always talk
about small tweaks lead to giant Peaks
and you want to make sure that you're
making small tweaks to each piece it can
be overwhelming because isolating what
the issue is can mean hitting multiple
things you know and speaking of that
just as a reminder tonight is the
deadline of the tube influencer bundle
for those that know what that is if you
don't no worries but for those that
you're on the fence this is going down
at midnight y'all this is real deal so
if you're watching this on the replay
it's probably over but in 6 hours are
the special offer on our whole training
program with the video ranking Academy
as well as all of the bonuses including
you know growth video live tickets the
social media accelerator YouTube
influence hyper growth blueprint all of
the exclusive bonuses the whole thing
the deadline is tonight at midnight
that's 5:22 Friday May 22nd and so
anyways think media bundle is where that
all is um if you haven't heard about
growth video by the way I'm gonna take a
sip of coffee and and check this out
because these that you also get two
tickets to growth video live check this
out and I'll be right back sixty-five
percent of people use YouTube to help
them solve a problem but when I think
about this here's what question all of
us need to answer
what problem do you solve you got to
know that and when you know that people
are going to the internet they go to
Google they go to YouTube to help solve
a problem you need to be showing up with
those answers
my goodness so pumped for girl video
live and so if you are on the fence
about that bundle don't sleep jump in
and what are you drinking right now I
got a little coffee going even on a
Friday and somebody asked about the
think hat
unfortunately Howard we only have them
here in Vegas they're not shipping
online we do have a website I got it I
got to get them online I think media
merch calm why do we buy so many URLs I
don't know we have like a URL problem
and so we do have think medium merch you
get we've got some hoodies this is my
rising grind mug that I'm sipping on and
so uh a couple cool things that's all at
think medium merch and the Hat though
give me some time I'll find a way to get
the Hat going out there there's a couple
left in a storage unit we have them at
growth video live so another great
question that's on the YouTube side of
things can you unpack average view
duration what a great question because
average view duration is the metric
click-through rate an average view
duration are pretty much the two metric
metrics period oh man I'm gonna leave
you not you to get to my other channel
so here's think marketing but I got to
switch accounts we're gonna think media
and let's check some stuff out here okay
so what's a video that just blew up and
let's talk about maybe why so one of the
ones about backgrounds look at this my
goodness this little blue line good good
stuff I'll perform your typical video
which is the grey line down below here
okay and so average view duration really
good 30 39% pretty great here's here's
here's the bottom line you want to get
this to 50% or higher you hit 60% you're
like killing man so let's go how to make
a video with your phone
okay well this one is 40 minutes so it's
not gonna be a very good average view
duration but the video is doing well
because it's 40 minutes but let's do one
and who shout out to Heather Taurus if
you're part of the YouTube influence
challenge how to make a video on your
phone and the five-minute version that's
a whole nother level of strategy that we
we talk about what's the video even
called smart phone be make let's let's
go back and let's switch to categories
and check out this this guy because this
is a this guy's a banger closer to 50%
and getting 7000 views every two days so
average view duration again you want the
higher the better
but the tipping point for really seeing
videos takeoff is over 50% and actually
here's another way we could find it okay
here we go this is the 5-minute video
and closer to 50% 42% yeah yep you'll
probably notice I think probably a lot
of the top video viewed videos now
longer videos aren't going to have as
good of high view duration this is
fascinating because it's a very long
live stream but with 10 minutes of watch
time only 23% but 10 minutes of watch
time that's quite a bit of time spent on
a video with 20,000 views every two days
and it's a little bit old now so try to
get your average view duration over 50%
a try to get 1% better with every upload
literally if you're like dude minds that
freaking like 3% we'll try to get it to
4 and but then try to get it over 50%
and if you can really keep a video lean
mean and hold the audience attention
you'll be really onto something
triggering the algorithm it's that and
click-through rate those are the two top
metrics if you can get that
click-through rate obviously best
practices thumbnails powerful titles a
lot of things like that are critical and
I need to make my way back over to think
marketing is now I'm logged into the
wrong
so I can keep hanging out with you and
see you there and now let's go back over
here hit the like button if you're
getting value if you are fired up on a
Friday night to be here what is the best
length of a video Josie I hope I said
your name right let me know video should
be as long as they need to be but as
short as possible try to make your
videos half short and twice strong most
of us could probably make our videos
shorter but twice as strong edit your
videos like I know that sometimes the
editing is a learning curve but if you
shoot a twenty minute kind of talking
head video teaching something you can
probably easily edit it into ten by
taking out unnecessary parts like make
the content stronger be brief be bright
be fun be done and so I mean I'm about
to do a nine I'm in the middle of a 90
minute livestream or so you know I'm
just here to vibe and add value and hang
out with you so it's probably not a very
good video length but the videos that
we're doing over on think media maybe
that's something worth looking at I
think that you know we have a whole team
of content creators and that whole team
by the way you know I started I'm a
college dropout started by myself
started making videos in my bedroom you
know and if you've never seen my first
video like just have a look at it
because this whole thing started with
just me doing this alright so this is I
guess the first Sean thinks vlog and I'm
gonna try to vlog every single day
mainly so I can remember what I'm even
doing and what's going on because I just
feel like I have a lot that I'm thinking
about and I figured hey why not share it
and if you find something interesting
that's awesome now this is definitely as
real as it gets
so I'm not going to try to be energetic
or entertaining though maybe sometimes I
will
but anyways and I think it's important
to know that that video
was not edited I jump cut it when I was
editing like the little clip down so not
only was that I'm not gonna be energetic
or entertaining apparently but it was
super boring and super long even jump
cuts could have made that better so I
started shooting videos no clearly in my
home office without energy and and now
yours later you know think media is like
a team I've tried to grow as a leader
you know building a company and we're an
education company that you know helps
people and learn how to build their
influence with online video and helps
business owners so we had people like
Nolan on the team who is a really good
creator you know and these are like
people have grown a relationship with
and we've hired and whatnot so if you
see what he's doing here pretty advanced
just meaning he's learned video editing
but we're using b-roll you know these
are from like stock video sites and
there's a lot happening in the hook even
though there's less happening during
there's quite a bit of editing happening
and it's seven minutes long so that's my
point is you know I think another
Heather Taurus who's one of our trainers
and certified pic media coaches um if
you look at like home school versus
public school you know she didn't know
how to edit she didn't know how to shoot
video she didn't know anything back when
we met and I was one of the reasons why
she kind of joined the team she wanted
to learn video though I mean and she
helped with business and
entrepreneurship stuff but she did a
talking head video in front of a plain
beige wall maybe not the best decision
could have been a more interesting
background hey this video has over a
hundred thousand views and there's jump
cuts you know she put some titles in a
little black and white little you know
details making it more interesting and
so she turned her energy up a little bit
and then followed the system that we
teach you know inside of video ranking
Academy and a hundred and four thousand
views it's still getting views so what
was the question how long should videos
be seven minutes it she shot for two
hours and then had to edit it down and
it took her like seven hours to edit it
over mult
nights and she was just getting started
you know trying to do the homeschool
thing trying to raise her kid so like
it's worth it though to put in the time
to make the video more interesting more
attention-grabbing longer view duration
because then you get that click-through
rate you get that average view duration
you rank the video in search and so I
hope that helps that uh can really you
know be a needle mover cream always
rises to the top no matter how many cups
of coffee you pour I'll cheers to that
come on rise & grind all right Glen asks
which option is best 60 percent
suggested five percent search or 60
percent search and five percent
suggested well probably Glen 60 percent
suggested because the rich get richer
quote-unquote on YouTube and suggested
videos and browse features is the most
powerful force on YouTube but it's an
impossible question to answer because if
you were getting 60 percent youtube
search for like how to lose weight those
three words you had the number one video
on youtube for how to lose weight and
you had a fitness company or a
supplement company you'd be destroying
the game you know so there's a lot of
variables there both are the desire and
and like what we teaches go after both
we believe a ranked video is ranking in
search or suggested or both that's what
a ranked video is a video that gets
views 24/7 365 or whether you upload new
videos or not you know that just has a
life of its own and so I would consider
that I'm looking for an external mic I
have a Samsung S 20 ultra any
recommendations hmm
so let's let's what is a samsung s 20
ultra question number one for all people
is your headphone jack and and I am mad
okay you don't have one so I'm assuming
and shout me out Samsung peeps you got
some kind of a dongle right so okay so
you need this this guy okay great
so let's just assume and you probably
already know that you you have that it
probably comes in the box so you got to
plug this in then you have a smartphone
jack
this will rock your word world yeah
people y'all people struggle because of
trrs versus TRS if you're ever wondering
why a mic is not working is because of
this right here
so people try to plug back the rode
video you know shotgun mic in and it's a
TRS plug tip ring sleeve left and right
is on this trrs is tip ring ring sleeve
left right microphone and even the way
things are spaced out so this trrs is a
smart phone plug okay and then TRS is
like an audio jack plug let's get crazy
ya'll guys getting value out of this so
this is just a normal TRS plug just a
normal you I don't even know if you
could really see it but to rings you can
you know you can trust me oh if I put it
on the black okay
just a normal shotgun mic not meant for
smartphones okay so knowing that you
want to get a smart mote smart phone
dedicated microphone one of my favorites
if you don't mind a lot of cable is a
boil you im1 20 bucks and you can plug
it in and here's the deal tip ring ring
sleeve see the three rings on there okay
now watch this road SC for it this guy
or you can get a you can get the mobile
one truth is it's all the same maybe
like so long as there's good reviews you
can plug in this to your dongle and then
this
to any mic that's like this that's like
maybe a DSLR Mike you're on land so you
can now use this mic in your smartphone
because you you put the sc4 on the end
there or the the mofo MC 3 the key is
knowing that in smartphones it's it's
trrs and then that in like a camera it's
TRS and then just converting back and
forth eventually as content creators and
entrepreneurs that are creating content
you want to have a couple of these
pieces in your kit with you at all times
so in my bag when I'm traveling on the
road I've got in case of emergencies do
I need to create some content I've got a
lav mic that I can plug in to my phone
and it's got tip ring ring sleeve so
it's a smart phone laughs Mike I'm ready
to go at any time
just keep that in my bag and then I've
also got this in my bag at all times so
I'm like okay do I want to use a shotgun
mic with my with my smartphone or some
other kind of mic and then by the way
the reverse is true I don't mean to take
so much time here but let me know if
you're getting value road SC three pigs
eat the trrs and makes it into the other
one so if you're like shoot all I got is
a smartphone mic but I want to plug it
into my DSLR then you can convert back
so if you had these two cables you could
make any mic do anything that you want
lucky says this is the content I was
looking for my man reach 1000 subs said
it this way trrs is the audio jack for
smartphones and TRS is the audio jack
for cameras summed up great and I hope
you got value out of this besides my
coffee I'm sipping on some electrolytes
over here so creative is about to buy
the book hey man I appreciate it wrote a
book called YouTube secrets appreciate
it we have the audio book tune in and so
if you like audio books have you read
YouTube secrets let me know
okay I just updated some of my old
videos new titles descriptions and
thumbnails what are the odds that they
get more traction in the future um
depends on how big your channel is
depends on if they have any momentum
right now the biggest the best way to
get them traction if you don't have any
is you got to be sharing them on social
because that's where you're gonna bring
in some new traffic to see if they take
off in the YouTube algorithm for
everybody watching you have a little
momentum you're like wow this video gets
like a view or two a day that's like
kind of real-time traffic a title or a
thumbnail pivot might get that two three
or four views a day click-through rate
goes up a little bit and it might
actually get it to take off so we break
that down in depth in some of our
training but but does that make sense
you either want to send traffic
externally cuz you don't have any
momentum but if you have momentum you
could get more by changing some of those
elements but you don't want to mess
necessarily with the thing that's
working because you also could go the
other way whoops and so that's a risk
you might be willing to take you develop
an intuition and it's nice to have kind
of principles and best practices over
time but of course you know we all make
mistakes because you in a way you're
testing it here's the cool thing with
YouTube let me show you what I mean you
want to go in and what she you want to
give it some time so you might be like
okay here's the click-through rate it's
like going up a little and then it's
like hanging around 44.3%
so you upload a different thumbnail
split testing is you only change one
thing at a time if you change the
thumbnail in the title it either goes
down or up you don't necessarily know
what caused it so then maybe you want to
give it three four days of a new
thumbnail and you're like oh shoot it
dropped two percent click-through rate
or oh great it went up to six percent
click-through rate those are some of the
pivots you can make great question is
the tube starter kit going back on sale
I just missed it last night I got
distracted while taking notes
tube starter kit if you're curious is
that tube starter kit com
I don't yet so it's back up at full
price of 97 right now and it's if you
want to check this out there's a lot of
stuff in here including our title guide
and some thumbnail training um it will
go on sale in the future in probably six
months meaning like we'll probably I
could Cyber Monday Black Friday
I won't encourage you when you look at
everything that's in there we've added
up like six hundred and thirty two
dollars worth of stuff and so you know
sorry you missed out and definitely you
could grab it later but it's a crazy
discount still the full full price is
gonna be 197 next week we are gonna be
doing some more you know we want to
honor the fast action movers and I'm
sorry to miss that but it's still a
super good deal at the price that it's
at okay yeah yeah good to see Heather
here are thick media bundle if you have
heard about that or haven't heard about
that that has six hours until 50% off
sale ends and the bonus has changed
that's that thick media bundle calm
thanks for the shout Heather and drop a
question my name is Shawn connolley
thanks for being here and we're doing
some QA my energy is at a solid five and
a half right now because it's been a
crazy week but I wanted to come on hang
out and I'm hanging out with you over
here on Facebook and the think marketing
channel so smash like if you are
grateful that it's Friday TGIF the grind
includes Friday thank God it's Friday
thank God I'm free how many drinks you
got that's a great question first of all
I've got some ionized alkaline water one
I've got a mason jar of alkaline water
two
I've got a rise & grind mug of some
Ethiopia coffee hmm
arrow pressed I've got a electrolytes
drink four and I've got another glass of
water five that is so funny like it
wasn't until you asked that I was like
what is happening this is not an
unnatural though this is I live in utter
chaos at all times or utter hydration
depending on how you look at it that's
probably what it is and so hey yeah if
you someone asks about channel reviews
if you would like a channel review type
what your niche is if you're on think
marketing and type what your niche is
and drop a link if you're on Facebook
Wendy that is why your boy is not
working with your phone and now you can
fix it although your boyish should be
working with your phone but because it
is for phones but that could fix it yeah
Geoffrey how do you compete with high
volume high demand keywords pretty
intense question because sometimes you
could go look at YouTube and actually
see just because there's maybe a high
volume goes to actually look on YouTube
like do research of what the top videos
are study those a little bit and then
don't maybe the other option like find
flank the enemy not that anyone's the
enemy but you get it flank your
competitors so I just did coaching with
a woman and she was had had wrote a book
on chronic illness and one of the things
she she overcome a couple different
chronic illnesses and so she um dang it
I can't copy paste your guys's links
from Facebook
oh I know what I'll do and so she
started to narrow down on one of the
specific things she had been through and
there was a lot less competition about
that so sometimes the move
is to niche down they say in internet
marketing the riches are in the niches
if you've never heard of that phrase
it's important phrase kind of you know
seems almost kind of douchey but but uh
but the riches are in the niches you
know like it's a it's niching down and
then eventually you know you can stand
out more because once you have influence
you can do a lot of you can do anything
you want more you could compete so it's
like you can go up more
david-and-goliath but you learned some
principles there's so many variables in
like auditing the competition and so
alright let's do a channel review so NYC
capture photography good stuff let's
look at here about I would not gonna
change the game but I would love to see
a little bit more detailed of a
description you do it you probably need
to say subscribe because it already says
subscribe right here in a giant red
button so you don't have to like re have
me click subscribe you therefore you
could make that your website if this is
your website killer photography by the
way so I would make may be your website
if that's what you want people to do is
go to your website do you want people to
go to Facebook I'm a big fan of getting
rid of social media networks you don't
you care less about if you do that's
great but like less is more like if if
like this isn't the best avatar not that
we're here to take talk about Facebook
and growing your influence on Facebook
might be tough up to you but all I'm
saying is like photography seems so
Instagram to me so if it was like
website and Instagram it's like cool
that's like you know you could be a
little more focused um I think one thing
to encourage you with is when you're
this early in the game it's all about
volume like it's your first 35 to 55
videos posted live video session I'm not
being critical at all but you could get
a USB mic or get the mic closer to your
mouth because
definitely have the room echo of of your
room I don't think that's going to make
a ton of difference on the tutorial but
just an observation and obviously
something to invest in but you can you
can hear it and then there's even a hiss
on the audio again I don't think that's
gonna change the result of the videos
results this could be probably titled
better um valuable but what am I going
to learn um give me something specific
like even Photoshop like seven photos
live photo editing session and Photoshop
tips like already that would be better
and a little bit more searchable like
this
you did hear how to do a detailed
portrait edit in Photoshop your audio
already sounds better there so I may
have just caught one year so loving that
um and next thing I would say this looks
cool I was gonna say vary up your
content formats looks like you are nice
nice nice so this is a this is a so I
mean there's definitely some stuff here
but you're just off to an awesome start
I think as you're finding kind of your
voice in your momentum on YouTube a lot
of what we're looking at here is putting
out you know some initial videos I think
you know literally getting into a volume
of videos one thing that is a fact about
YouTube channels that allow that'll
benefit everybody here is you want to
break out video what we're after is a
break out video that kind of triggers
growth on our channel so let me pass the
question off to you what video that
short punchy powerful that would attract
your target audience could lend itself
to being a breakout video I might meet
you as a stranger these could be better
thumbnails - I realize these probably
aren't your best you know foot forward
but like even even the crop of the
is you know like what's really happening
here it's actually kind of a cool crop
but like you get it these are of course
much stronger and that's awesome too so
it seems like this is where the ramp up
is really starting right so but what
could be a punchy video that you put
some energy into that delivers some
quick value again that's gonna attract
your target audience killer stuff though
and and you've got talent so and
obviously mastery in your crafts you're
movin on YouTube so you're off to a
great start
Gela I'm seeing that this live has a
subtitle are you streaming from stream
yard and how do you add the subtitle
while on live so when streaming from
stream yard you on the right side have
comments banners brand private chat all
that stuff and when you have the
facebook comments integrated you can
just click the plus button and add them
right on I don't think that is a play
button I don't think it's a paid feature
I mean I'm like I can't speak at all
there's nothing good coming from here on
out like it's it's the ship is sinking
my friends you're gonna watch a man
disintegrate into his own fatigue over
the next 60 minutes just kidding I feel
pretty good but I may not be able to
speak well where was I gonna go next
think media tools we talk about our
tools stream yard oh yeah there's a free
version of stream yard and it has a
watermark and then there's a okay I'm
already logged in here so I can't really
look at what the options are but yeah I
think you know when you pay you can go
you can get rid of the watermark you
know I have you can't really see it I'll
put the black one there's a lot of think
happening
how many thinks can we get into the
scene can we try that just like how many
glasses I have cap type in the comments
how many thinks are on screen right now
and the winner gets a channel review I
bet a lot of people will win how many
thinks so you could you could control
the watermark I just turned it white you
know normally it's powered by stream
yard but you don't have it's nice what
this shows up on Oh
exposed when it has the shadow I'm gonna
take it off cuz there's I got I got a
decent think right up above me for Wendy
wins wendy I'd love to do a channel
review if you got your seven Laurie says
that it's possible I suppose like where
else are the other ones that was awesome
hit like for the delirious livestream at
the end of the week Chris and Yuki over
on YouTube so I can't pull it in says
why family vlogging YouTube channels
rarely grow that's a really great
question well Chris and Yuki a few
things and if I'm here for coaching you
showed up to this coaching session for
QA you don't even have an avatar man you
gotta have an avatar you got a a bit
about switching into being serious like
there's something about or maybe you do
that God like completely rude like
apparently you might and I just couldn't
see it on think marketing I take it back
and I was a little saucy so you know I
think you got us you got to say why is
this different that's what I want you to
think different is better than better
what makes you different um here's a
really good question
my friends let's get into it I need to
just finish this coffee and then things
will really get fired up here's why I
want you to write your about page right
we do this in our clarity blueprint I
want you to write your about page for
yourself like it's not that people are
gonna go to your about page I want you
to spend time writing out your about
page and I want you to write words that
describe powerfully how you're different
so here's the come to Jesus moment just
a young married couple with a with a kid
enjoying life can I tell you it's
straight you're like no you can't
flatter me okay we're here and I'm in
saucy mode
do that it's not different you know how
many young married couples with a kid
that are enjoying life okay let's keep
going you will see reaction videos
challenges vlogs and marriage content
join us on the journey come on right so
I just mean like you need to stand out
in the sea of sameness so how are you
different different is better than
better one example that we attempt on
think media at a pretty good success
rate is there's lots of tech channels
but we are not reviewing the latest
smartphone of the latest Samsung phone
I'm not talking about 3d printers I'm
not talking about consumer electronics
we niche down to say tools for creators
cameras lighting tools for creators so
in the past I was covering a lot of
headphones more as a hobby excuse me you
don't need headphones I mean you get
like one pair of headphones it's like
gonna change your creation game but we
could do tools for creators logo Pro
whatever and so I've I'm just trying to
help you with my journey right how can
you be different it's not actually that
you can't be a vlog Channel but here's
the vlog channels that really succeed
like homesteading in Alaska my gosh
that's different
homesteading period whoa these guys
don't have power they're living off the
land other ways to be different Chris
and Yuki is like a faith perspective
living out our beliefs in in a world in
that in a world that doesn't agree with
them and like really amplifying your
difference because right now you're
you're just it's I'm not I love you so
much but you're just you actually say
that just a young married couple with a
kid enjoying life dude you and 10,000
other people so it's it could be hard
figuring out your difference
what's your difference different is
better than better Sally hogshead said
that different is better than better
which is really good news
you're not gonna be better than huge
established vloggers you're not gonna be
better than Casey Neistat vlogging every
day and spending 12 hours editing and
making these short films you know like
he carved out his niche that's relieving
what a breath of fresh air I'm not
trying to be better than somebody who's
better than me I just need to be me
times to be you times to amplify your
difference amplify your unique
perspective and sometimes the way you
could do that is by marrying a couple
things together
marrying you were different because this
is like whether it's leaning into like
an ethnicity age where you live what
your beliefs are what your backgrounds
are or potentially pivoting your channel
because there's a lot of a lot of
channels want to just be reactions
challenges and vlogs a lot of channels
want to you know and and is their
competition and gardening shows their
competition in real estate yes but is
their competition in Arizona real estate
less is your competition in going all-in
on Nikon less is there a competition on
going all-in on Fuji and just kind of
going to it being different and you know
we don't people say Shawn why don't you
cover Nikon we're like do we can't cover
everything only know so much man it's
enough to try to like learn and master
Canon learn and master Sony those are
the two big ones for video I'd be happy
to cover Nikon as the energy starts to
rise but that's an opportunity my friend
Chelsea Nicole photography is like all
of an icon shooter it's a point of
difference Tony I'm glad you got value
out of that smart like I mean that to
smarsh like let's see what we got here
you shout-out Gary Vee a fair amount
have you had the opportunity to do
content with them so for a Gary Vee and
I uh let me see here there is the Gary
Vee crush crush crush
Blagh
crushing crushing it good book I'm not
gonna be able to find that crushing it
Gary Sean kennel oh here we go you know
it's not a saying hey we got okay cool
cool cool yeah yeah this was kind of
cool so this is Gary's medium blog right
and I get to tell my story about how my
wife almost died in my arms in the
winter of 2019 and how while I was in
the hospital room and that's when I
listened to a copy of Gary these CD and
my laptop I'm gonna share a link to this
is pretty cool blog so that was that was
kind of a fun full circle moment when it
came to Gary stuff and so I'll post that
in the comments and on the YouTube chat
that's on his medium calm crushing it
blog we've had Gary Vee on video
influencers 2 times I had a chance to go
to New York with Benji for the first
time from video influencers co-author of
YouTube secrets this sounds bad though
but like that's just so far left Gary so
much but I was like that's just last a
long flight just to be in and out so we
sent a videographer friend of ours John
MIDI on and Benji and I was like you
guys do it man and they sent me the
footage I edited the footage and I was
like I know he's gonna be in out of the
office and like someday we'll connect
you know I've heard him speak and got to
ask him a question on the mic a couple
times at events and and that's about it
and loved him so what what a guy Gary
these impacted my life a lot and on
Facebook that comment did not work but
maybe it will and she'll did that go
through that time let me if you're on
we're doing questions and if you're just
joining I mean a Shawn channel i'm the
author of youtube secrets and it's a
Friday night and that comment just made
it to one of the Facebook pages yeah
inside of the challenge Facebook group
if you want to check out that article
let's talk about YouTube let's talk
about social media let's talk about big
and let's talk about Mohammed's question
is it true that you may have great
content but if you have low subscriber
count people will not subscribe because
they would just assume your channel is
not good I don't think that's true I
know you can hide your subscriber count'
I do think there's a point in time with
my lightsaber here of my ruler that like
we think the appearance of success which
is true like you know what I mean if you
see a YouTube video that like it
suggested to you and you're like seventy
five thousand views like and that's
probably like other people have watched
it so that's like what our mentality is
so I could see not turning on your
subscriber count' early on potentially
but what I love about YouTube is video
stand alone like the secret to success
on YouTube is videos not subscribers
okay well you need subscribers because
they get distributed to your videos get
distributed them it can help your
channel grow and so I'm not saying you
shouldn't grow subscribers but like
videos grow on YouTube in fact there
could be channels with a lot of
subscribers that don't get views anymore
maybe the channel is old like right now
we're getting about 4.2 million
subscribe use a month our view to
subscriber ratio and think media as a
variety channels not super good but
we're a super variety channel not
everybody wants to edit on movie I movie
when they edit on premiere and they
already have an a 6400 so they don't
care about the m6 so we have kind of
like a lot of fish in the sea and those
different fish are of different sizes so
we got whales and one whale could be
like one video and then we got minnows
but we we have expect massive take over
the whole ocean strategy that's
happening so I think I would focus on
making good videos you can hide your
subscriber count if you want get up to a
thousand or whatever but when you get
that breakout video it's not gonna
matter that video can take on a life of
its own and then grow your channel for
you so
how do you categorize your channel when
experimenting with content you may not
need to seem that your channel name in
this case is so creative you can just
experiment and maybe change your channel
name later the easiest answer is your
first and last name my channel is called
Sean kennel the one that I experimented
on the most and when it's your first and
last name even though it may not be
successful it's honest what's on this
channel stuff that I uploaded shot
channel stuff
what's your niche Sean kennel might not
be successful but it's a good playground
to play in because whatever I wanted to
talk about that day a vlog that day did
a cooking video that day so that's where
my education really got accelerated was
by posting lots of random videos on my
personal channel and so then I got super
clear and got super passionate about
starting a niche channel because I think
that's where the magic really is on
YouTube catch that tip if it made sense
what's your take on using landing pages
to capture leads for affiliate products
instead of posting affiliate links
correctly I would only do that on like
bigger ticket stuff you want some ninja
hacks no we don't okay never mind I will
give you an e just kidding neuro tropics
mm-hmm anybody in DeNiro tropics you
want a really profitable niche I don't
know if anyone has this and so what's
the neurotropic neurotropic is who knows
if they work it's like brain pills like
B vitamins and stuff
okay so neurotropic in this case this is
an e-commerce store all right
so and this is maybe not even what I'm
looking for so that's actually yo calm
I'm looking for neurotropic review so
this would be an affiliate mark
in play there's an if here's an
affiliate marketing blog uh let's
actually even check this out this is
smart stuff here you get you're getting
some strata strategy neurotropic alpha
brain for one week not sponsored I have
no affiliation okay this is actually no
affiliate link she could have put an
affiliate link here but she really
wanted to just try it and so cool that's
not an affiliate play here you go
this probably is dr. Brady reveals
qualia and here is an affiliate link
okay it's a udemy course wow that's an
affiliate link to though linking to an
online course great and apparently not
even linking to the products hmm not not
even where I'm going but these are all
your you getting inside so you get value
out of this this even like other things
okay a review scout spoke pretty good
these would be affiliate links to I
don't think okay things to avoid top
five alright I want to buy brain dynamic
let me buy it okay you can see this kind
of code up here probably an affiliate
link of some kind by now and and and now
I'm in the affiliate link place okay so
here's the point of like building a
messenger bot if I give this a messenger
they'll sign me up for messenger I get a
little 10 percent off but then they
could keep marketing to me more um where
am I going with all this I'm going with
the idea that without finding it right
now that there's neurotropic websites
when you're like me and you get into
like biohacking and like you know peak
performance and energy and stuff so I
take some neurotropic so that Brendon
Burchard made that are called like hpx
life or something and I've tried other
ones and so you can get on an email list
of like a review blog and your goal
would be to capture somebody who's
interested in more of the same
thing then that would make sense but
typically I would much rather just have
like one YouTube video maybe compare two
different neurotropic s-- links to both
in the description and go just rate to
the sale so actually an answer your
question
it'd be like both and it would be it
depends on what you want to do but then
more than that a big strategy in
affiliate marketing could be to build up
like an email list of people that are
interested in a particular thing and
especially if maybe it's higher ticket
because a lot of these things if it's
like a $30 supplement or a $40 you know
then then you may just go direct to the
sale but yeah I hope that adds value a
little bit of both when you are starting
a YouTube channel do you recommend
shooting indoors or outdoors nice thing
about outdoors during the day provided
the weather's nice and typically you
don't want to shoot in direct sunlight
there's a tip Jessica because it's hard
to expose for direct sunlight you know
it's like plus you'll squint or you wear
sunglasses which kind of breaks the
intimacy but if it's overcast that's the
ideal time to shoot a lot of times here
in Vegas we won't shoot outside because
it's it's super sunny um you know and
hot rather is the bigger issue like a
hundred degrees so indoors is nice
because it's more controllable it's more
consistent if you set up lighting that's
maybe the nicest thing to have is
somewhere to shoot in your house that is
consistent you know you might be like I
got 40 kids man it's it's like it's
never consistent but like consistent
audio consistent light consistent place
where you can create consistent content
because consistency is king on YouTube
and if you want to be taken seriously
then you got to be consistent survey how
many times did I say consistent just
that just kidding and so yeah I think
that it either way Jessica just start
both it's a good day and it's good
lighting shoot outside if you got a good
place to shoot inside shoot inside and
then make it a goal to just be
consistent either way
yeah yeah yeah all right
I don't even know how to take this
off-screen okay hit the like button if
you are getting value what affiliate
marketing can do for home and auto
insurance selling quotes is pretty low
when you don't have high volume and no
one wants to affiliate when you're not
huge got it so you're not getting
approved for the affiliate program build
your influence first build your
influence first you can see look look at
the top of this ruler see how it says
influence right there then right below
it says income and then it says impact
that's the order build your influence
first yeah so that you could sign up for
some of those things one of the hacks I
know they want to see traffic but I
really recommend starting a blog - I
know that's like another thing to create
but sometimes affiliate programs take
blogs more seriously like professional
blogs Squarespace Wix you know Heather
Taurus has a blog and that could that
helped her and I don't think she's
updated it but it doesn't matter because
it um it gives you a place like I think
she just redirected it to her website oh
I know like if I could probably still
find it uh and and if you want to get
approved you're just starting your
YouTube channel for affiliate programs
and stuff doc Oh hmm so so this you know
Heather's got all kinds of skills um but
like this is a nice thing to submit to
the Amazon affiliate program or to other
so all it is is like a little collection
of some videos and you know what I'm
saying like okay so you think about this
this is really good to lean in for it
you want to get proof for affiliate
program you got like a big banner up top
like Heather tourist homeschool
motherhood boom brand niche awesome nice
clean photography awesome couple videos
great low download grower email list
awesome and and pretty simple and even
if it's not updated and if you want to
reach out or work with a brand they go
okay
consistent message consistent brand
consistent content Kapow so early on I
know she has 16,000 subscribers now but
early on she was and that's just a
little side project for she was hustling
doing things like that and that's a Wix
site Wix so consider that to get
approved for you know auto insurance
other affiliate programs but build your
influence first build your influence
first hey if you're getting value out of
this stream my energy goes up every time
you leave a comment I need what is that
movie tell me the movie I need you to
believe in me or else I'll shrink and
disappear American Gods that was a weird
place to take it but that's true my
strength is correlated to your belief is
it fairies Tinker Bell what's the thing
that's like to the degree with which the
office when when Nellie was like you
everyone has to believe in me as manager
and Hornet for me to really exist that's
where I'm going right now is because
it's been a crazy week shout out if
you're part of the YouTube challenge
I've probably never done a YouTube
stream this low energy but now you're
catching me trying to just just make it
coffee's done for other drinks to
consume tony says I believe whoo whoo
whoo I love your energy couple
announcements we have a free web class
that I teach some really ninja stuff
about earning money 4050 minutes of
content and then it talks a little bit
about our alright su special that we're
running right now and so this heads up
don't miss this it's legit coming down
in five hours sometimes we leave up our
webinars web classes on replay this one
is not the case so idea to income dot
tips link in the description below on
YouTube don't miss this one at the end
of it you will hear more about which if
you haven't heard yet about our to
YouTube influence coaching bundle and I
just want you to not miss this because
we you may email us or text us tomorrow
this is going away at midnight West
Coast time as well and if you would want
the ultimate course and coaching bundle
with our proprietary process taught
in-depth again that's that think media
bundle calm and so shout out if you've
already jumped in we're doing a party
tomorrow morning I'm gonna be rested and
fired up we got Heather we got Tony
we're doing a welcome party that's
starting at 9:00 a.m. Pt tomorrow and so
all this is in here including coaching
calls camera confidence with Heather and
I lifetime access all the things don't
miss that tube not think media bundle
comm what's up I got the bundle I don't
see who you are but thank you Facebook
user I just can't see from my window
right here and so Richard saying paste
the link out to the class okay so it's
at it's that idea to you know watch it
anytime you want it just comes down
tonight I did to income got tips and
that should have just worked I just
posted it I don't know if it is working
though in the it looks like it did so
there you go idea to income dot tips
check that out Eric see tomorrow super
pumps l-boogie or l-boogie super pumps
are coming grateful you're part of our
community I mean all I'm in the think
media courses let's go lightsaber just
finished the challenge enjoying the VRA
fam let me see if I can find your link
depends on cuz I can't get it out of
stream yards just give me a second take
a sip of your beverage hug your dog if
you don't got a dog hug your partner if
you don't got a partner hug your spouse
if you don't got a spouse hug yourself
come on self love I can't get to your
link I'm not seeing in the challenge
um we got this though let's keep it
going
Glenn is it advisable to have more than
one income stream at the beginning or
should I focus on one it is advisable to
focus on one Glenn what is the shortest
path to income or revenue for you
alright and so we're in creative mode
now and I'm gonna it's arts and crafts
so everybody get ready go ahead and and
get ready for arts and crafts time
because I want to drop some content on
you help to help with your journey
looking for some arts looking for some
crafts alright so my friend Glenn here's
the big question how many income streams
should you have this could be income
this could be influence streams - here's
where what we all need to do as
entrepreneurs and what we could benefit
from a couple books to recommend
essentialism power of focus a couple
books to recommend the one thing Gary
Keller I think wrote that the power of
focus you can do anything but you can't
do everything you can actually do
everything just not all at once though
so here's what happens alright but shout
out in the comments if you're creative
or a business owner or an entrepreneur
so you are here and you're on this
island right here right of man I got a
dream I got a vision I got something I
want to build I want to start a YouTube
channel I want to in fact you're not
smiling like this guy you're actually
unhappy man because you're like I'm
optimistic but I don't have my results
yet now over here for our purposes we're
on a mission here at thick media to help
10,000 people create a full-time living
doing what they love while making a
difference in the world with online
video so to make a full-time living
we're gonna have to actually reach the
money so let's just use that on the
other side this could be the impact the
audience to subscribe
okay now there's a lot of cool ways to
do this online you know YouTube we hope
we kind of joke it's not all about
YouTube YouTube is a a place to build
your influence YouTube is a place to get
known YouTube is a place to get your
message out but your way of actually
maybe monetizing or really impacting
people at a different level could be
writing a book
it could be starting a Facebook group
and moving people into a community on a
Facebook group it could be building an
email list of people who say I want a
newsletter I mean there's been times
like Chris Brogan where I would read his
newsletter every Sunday like I followed
him for his newsletter like Ryan holiday
you know so it could be an email list it
could be like a text message list like
whatever but YouTube's just the way to
get in front of them it could be patreon
subscribers eventually and then you
upload you know what I mean okay shout
out to me in the comments so if you're
creative and you can relate to this you
start a lot of things you start a lot of
projects so you only got a few
subscribers 2200 but you have more than
one YouTube channel even so and maybe a
while back you started your YouTube
channel it's a couple years old so you
start your YouTube channel and you start
to like build it right and you're
building it out to go to you to this
destiny or the destination or the other
side and you know you're kind of like
uploading consistently and then you
aren't and then you build on it a little
bit more and this guy right here now we
need more resources for craft I'm why
can't we have nicely oh here we go oh my
friends this Friday
red okay as as Sean utterly has a
meltdown and disintegrates okay on
camera all right you too so there's your
YouTube bridge
but what ends up happening though to a
lot of us is we go to an event you know
we listen to Gary Vee and he's like dude
audio is the frickin future he's like do
- everything's audio anchor audio voice
voice is the future voice audio you got
to start a podcast and you go you know I
haven't really got results on YouTube
yet so I'm gonna start a podcast yeah
okay and like that's how far you get
though you spend like a month trying to
figure out the name and and you like you
upload one episode and or you don't even
do that you actually just aren't
planning phase you just journaling about
it you got like four names I met
somebody who came to Vegas influencers
the other day and was like went back
before the lockdown
and and introduced herself and let me
know about all she was doing and I was
terrified for her sake because she was
like I'm a freelance videographer I'm a
social media manager I'm a youtuber I'm
a podcaster and here's the thing though
I'm thinking about starting my branding
agency and I was like okay hold the
phone sis but maybe you can relate to
that could be why you're frustrated
tired or staying stuck so then you're
like okay well to make money on the side
I got a day job so then even on top of
this like your day job is actually let's
be honest is your way to get money you
got to get money somehow but it's like a
tiny little tightrope or you want to
transfer that and you want to build out
a different way to make revenue so maybe
that is how you pay your full-time job
but that's taking you I mean that I
don't know you work 40 hours a week
don't you right gotta work gotta pay the
bills somehow so and you're trying to
reproduce that flow somewhere else so
then you're like you know what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna do freelance I'm starting a
freelance agency and we're not gonna say
that she you've made it all the way to
money because one person paid you 200
bucks like one time you know your cousin
or like a business owner and it was like
under the table
got deal you know what I'm talking about
come on come on give me give me an amen
in the comments of you and that's so
you're kind of like freelancing so
you're trying to like build out your I'm
like a social media manager okay cool
great and then and then you think okay
well I want to write a book I want to I
want to UM you know do an e-book book or
something of some kind
this has got to be preaching to somebody
come on give me give me a like if you if
you fill in this I'm gonna outline my
book kind of like writing my books like
half done though you know so I'm
actually got pretty far on that or
where's your book it's in my head
where's your book it's on Google Docs
how much Oh No 30 pages okay cool so you
got your book going and then you got all
these things so like a conference pop
sets you're like then I got to go to
that book conference like writers summit
okay she go to that takes your energy
away and so what else you before I keep
going let me know what your projects are
tell me what your projects are in the
comments okay tell me what your projects
are what else can I put on this list
what are some things that you're working
on jack of all trades master of none
Chandler says creatives have a ton of
things my chair spins I feel yeah what
are your projects creative entrepreneur
I need a project I need one other
project a course of course a course of
course
so even though YouTube's not really
happening yet the podcast is not even
consistent the freelance thing is not
even inconsistent and so and and I like
this because you're here for help
Maggiore colas but I don't know why
you're writing to online courses while
finishing your book and your channel
this is for you and I love you and I'm
we're talking about this okay because
what I just heard is you've got course
one of course number one and then you've
got course number two which is maybe not
as far done okay and then you've got
your book and you've got your YouTube
channel and then with Wendy here let's
talk about Wendy's thing you down here
you've got your blog but the question is
is it making money Wendy let me know if
it is and it's fine if it's not but then
we got a blog down here too I'm gonna
circle that in orange just so we have a
little bit of color during craft time
and then we got course number one course
number two here's the here this is this
is most of us this is me can this is me
like this is me 2010 to 2015 even worse
was like YouTube channel you know
YouTube channel one and two I like three
YouTube channels so can we talk about it
YouTube channel two and then YT number
one dear god this is maybe all coming
together so look at look at this
god-awful picture we want to get to this
destination of revenue but we're
building fourteen things all at once
um and and it might only be two things
it might be three things but let me know
if this is resonating with you um and
what ends up happening is this you know
you're working on YouTube channel one so
you go out here and you're working and
you're building you're working and
you're building you're building but you
get distracted or you go
okay shoot I had to go all the way back
here because I got to get my blog going
again and I know I haven't done my blog
so this these are like your steps to
come down to your blog and you're
working on your blog okay less energy
underneath the mic let's move it down
Blagh Blagh Blagh oh man so close but ah
I blocks I'm really working
maybe blogs don't work okay let me go
back here
alright I'm gonna come up here Oh Gary B
says audio you start a podcast oh that
seems okay forget the podcast okay let
me get back to my YouTube channel but
kinda have to different hobbies so I'm
intro this other YouTube channel oh
shoot I need to upload on my other
YouTube channel though uh barely okay
but I'm going back okay should I gotta
pay the bills and I'm juggling my
full-time job which you know I got to do
regardless and I'm trying to get my
full-time job to 20 hours down to zero
okay let me do my do my freelance thing
I got 200 but it's kind of just a
trickle I was nice but that totally took
me off of distracted me for my blog and
distracted me for my youtube channel
makka grace is burning the candle at
both ends
Wendy says scarily accurate so here's my
question and answers to the multiple
streams of income question what would
happen if you got scarily focused and
you are started saying no to some of
your own projects and I'm listen you can
do you can do anything but you can't do
everything
hang on you can do everything but you
can't do it all at once I forgot I
completely forgot I forgot and I have no
more colors to help but I need a whole
separate sheet of paper because forget
all this you're trying to grow your
freakin influence on IG Facebook tik-tok
is cool now which is great you're
getting results like you got maybe not
results but you're getting views you got
I cheat so I'm leading the money but you
got Tik Tok Facebook IG a LinkedIn
videos hot now imagine if these we're
back here so you're trying to get these
going and you're freaking stressed
you know this is called it's a social
media hamster wheel you're on the
hamster wheel you're like okay I got a
got a post okay Shawn said one week one
video week on YouTube okay post post the
video oh shoot I got to update my
tick-tock Gary B said tik-tok okay gonna
post on tick-tock okay great
shoot I gotta keep my Instagram game I
haven't posted Oh Frank gotta open up
Instagram I need a new fo my phones live
honey bring me my other phone bring me a
phone
Instagram mr. Graham Instagram all right
I'm live over here on Facebook live hey
guys hang on and we got a post on
Instagram over here oh shoot just went
through the YouTube challenge okay back
to the YouTube YouTube YouTube YouTube
YouTube Oh what LinkedIn video LinkedIn
videos where it's at for business ok
LinkedIn LinkedIn LinkedIn like
generally the LinkedIn I'm happy I'm
building my business social media
hamster wheel ok oh shoot I gotta update
my youtube channel oh shoot my blog is
like six months behind okay I'm back
blog blog blog blog blog type type type
type type type okay going back all right
let's go back okay tick tock tick tock
tock tick tock all week and if I ticked
out of all week that's good because it's
a really favorable algorithm right now
so if I you post on tick tock then I can
get over to YouTube and and then I'll
get back and I'm posting on YouTube let
the man to stop y'all it's freakin
mayhem so it's not only that you're
trying to update as one human being with
a 40-hour job or a 20-hour job or 40
kids you know or a couple dependents or
whatever you got going on you're trying
to crush it as a single person a
solopreneur a side hustle season and
you're trying to be effective on every
social media platform while you're
writing your blog building two courses
finishing your book freelancing for
clients recording your podcast every
week and running two YouTube channels
see ya like
really ends the stream there I'm
exhausted
Dre I'm numb I'm exhausted draw on the
picture I want to recommend whether you
listen to it or not whether you get it
or not the concept of the book the one
thing let's just read the title together
a surprisingly simple truth behind
extraordinary results hmm we don't you
got to read the book like this isn't it
funny like book titles like summarize
like what they are you're like oh do one
thing and so we always say it's a great
book I recommend reading it and you get
strategies cuz you got a figure you want
there but Shaun how do I find my one
thing but Shaun is it okay to experiment
sure but we always say you can do
anything but you can't do everything but
listen you can do everything just not
all at once I'm really proud of how I
execute on LinkedIn Instagram Facebook I
need to get my tik-tok game alright
sorry I gotta go post on tic toc I got
to leave the live stream how many
courses I have right I'm pumped about
the results of my book I'm really pumped
about our podcast think marketing
podcast I'm pumped about my video
influencer shanem I think media channel
and I think marketing channel I'm not
trying to flex but I'm doing pretty well
with these things listen here's a
massive strategy this is why the divine
destiny set us up tonight for this
moment because this is gonna change your
life I did not do it all at flip and
once alright and when the aha moment hit
me I realized this and that's the read
plan listen you can either take the red
pen or the blue pill you made a wise
choice it's the red pen it's the secret
YouTube secrets like illustrations
one YouTube channel build your influence
now you can pick anything you want
I think the second largest search engine
in the world the only platform where
your content lives forever I think
YouTube is is an obvious choice is it
easy
no is it worth it yes so what would
happen if instead of if you said look
i'm just i'm just back burning all the
projects I'm back burning just
everything else because and and here's
what I did I said okay YouTube is my
platform 2015 October you may not have
heard this story before I had freelance
clients that's how I was paying the
bills so that was my 40-hour a week a
little bit more than that but they
started to transition me I got fired by
a freelance client first week in October
I was working for a church kind of
political maybe but you know like in her
corporate Church politics or whatever
because that was freaking Savage man you
know I wasn't good at what I was okay
whatever I was confident umm and so but
but they let me go and I had was making
five thousand a month I lost $2,000 okay
well I still got three thousand so then
I was like okay well let me focus on
these other two clients second week in
October
Britain got a phone call when my second
client was like we gotta let you go we
just I'm gonna focus on YouTube strategy
anymore shoot four grand
two weeks third week in October 2015 I
saw this one coming third client was
hiring other people like full-time staff
lived in Florida I was here in Vegas los
had third client thousand dollars a
month I was making five grand a month as
a freelancer that was my full-time job
living here in Vegas supporting my wife
my family I'm at about 60,000 a year
making around three to five hundred
dollars a month in affiliate marketing
extra so immediately I went all-in on
YouTube after freaking out fourth week
in October Ben and Jerry's Netflix
depression you get the you know like
stick your head in the sand you know
what like what's the what's the what's
the why even try but I got over that
because I had a good community around me
and I called up David Goldstein hey bro
what should I do man I lost all my
clients should I get more clients now
this was
this was my circumstance and I'll give
you a rule in a second that I think can
help but I got clear and I picked one
thing tell me in the comments right now
what should you one thing be like you
know deep down like what you should
focus on if you were gonna focus on one
thing so here's what I did I took all my
energy and I started building and
building and building and building man I
wasn't trying to write the YouTube
secrets I wasn't actually I was but it
back.we back-burnered it we literally
put it on pause because I said I can't
write the book and build at the same
time Benji and I wanted to write it we
waited for years we put the project on a
back burner build it build it build it
get to some profit you've seen how
powerful this is because your profits
gonna give you freedom but now step
number two might freak you out because
you go okay so get one bridge complete
and then start building another one no
wrong answer
step two build it bigger all right let's
get this trickle into a frickin River
dog let's get this thing rolling man
this is good let's get this thing built
up so now let me explain exactly how I
did it I was focusing on think media I
was focusing on affiliate marketing so
identified the channel identified the
niche identified the way of producing
profit it's not the only way to produce
profit and I said okay and I knew how to
rank videos and I was already I was
doing it for clients so when I didn't
have the clients I was like well I'm
gonna do this for myself
and that's what David spoke sense into
me he's like do you know what you know
how to do this you've been doing it it's
your time you know entrepreneurs at some
point has to jump off the cliff god just
kicked you off Dawg like that's how he
talks he's literally never said dog in
his life and you got to go all-in so I
went all-in and then I built it and from
October 2015
to January 1st 2016 I made for $4,500 in
January off the Amazon Associates
Program because I went all-in with one
thing I started working 50 60 70 80 hour
weeks because at this point I had
nothing else to do I don't have kids got
a baby on the way though and I I just
went all-in because when your life
depends on it and when you know your
focus and it's the power of one thing
and the other book is called
essentialism and it's essentialism I got
the freaking bridge bill and and then I
built the bridge bigger so after I made
four thousand five hundred what I do I
made more videos and then four thousand
five hundred became five thousand three
hundred and then Adsense went up a
little bit became five hundred six
hundred seven hundred eight hundred a
month and then eventually I got to 6,000
7,000 8,000 and then I hired an editor
even before that I stretched like as
soon as we could eat like Chipotle
without guac I wasn't at that wealth
level yet to order the guac
you've been ordering guac you can't even
for it you can't spend more than you
make come on that's what I defined - I
knew that I reach financial freedom when
I stopped worrying about guac I was like
they're like you know it's gonna be an
extra $17 right and I was like I don't
know load it on you know I made it
guacamole at Chipotle can I get an amen
drop a comment drop a like you got to
get your thing connected you got to
build a bridge and stop dividing your
energy on 14 other bridges but then once
you build a bridge don't try to go build
another one get that bridge going better
bigger you ready for step 3 who wants to
guess what step 3 is you guessed it
don't go build another bridge make your
freakin main bridge even bigger get that
into an interstate get more traffic
flowing on that piece that first year I
think I hit six figures from YouTube
like 128 or something because I still
focused on getting the freaking profit
flowing and I didn't divide my energy
about amongst a bunch of other things
when you've seen the power of this now
let's fast forward to today think
marketing podcast built second YouTube
channel built third YouTube channel
built that's number three they're all
profiting we got so many flows booked
built like you could go by and that's
done go by the audiobook like it's done
right and guess what because of this oh
man
that lit this guy on fire so other
projects by the way you know how easy
quote-unquote easy at West a lot of
podcasts it was still ton of work and
obviously I'm gonna tell you the secret
to this is team but the only way I could
afford a team is because I got some
freaking flow going from building an
actual bridge so I could reinvest in
scale my LinkedIn that's not great but I
guess what built my IG my IG is pretty
great wedgies not happening at a great
level without Melissa Caputo and I'm not
able to pay Melissa Caputo and I thought
I have some bridges bill Facebook
awesome
tik-tok oh man might as well give up
course built course to built need a blog
though if anybody's a writer and you're
looking for like you're really good at
blogging let's talk email me you seen
our power this fool this is you can do
anything you can't do everything you can
do everything that's not all at once and
so now think media and you've seen it
you're part of the challenge there's a
crew there let me know if you got value
out of this what's your aha moment and
what is this telling you to do next what
is this telling you to do nest what is
your next right move what's your next
two-three moves and what do you need to
stop doing probably one of the most
powerful questions right now is not what
you need to add to your life it's what
you need to take away from your life so
that you can get a trickle into a
River into a gusher and get your gusher
gushing at a whole level on a whole
nother level
which meant I don't have to go back to a
job I don't have to go back to freelance
work and I was able to make this
full-time living off youtube and then
fund every next project
season-by-season and I'll tell you this
it never stops you wanting to overextend
yourself if you're a creative
entrepreneur that's that's your nature
so I've we've had it in our heart to
launch the think marketing podcast for
over a year
like money coming in seven figures in
our business and like I think it'll
stretch us to thin multiple team members
don't know if we're ready now either
certain scenes where there's certain
seasons where you can stretch yourself
but this is the entrepreneurial dilemma
y'all this is what keeps so many people
stuck you're doing too many things if
you got a little focused in the short
term and got your one bridge complete
then you could use your one bridge to
fund your next bridge to fund your next
bridge and I think all your dreams can
come true
now disclaimer couple disclaimers when I
was doing YouTube I knew what my main
thing was and anything else just had to
support that main thing so that could
have been some social media but it was
for YouTube's sake so I don't have a
good Facebook page I don't have a good
Instagram I don't have like because
those weren't focuses but I would let
Instagram know you know I got a YouTube
video out or whatever because it was it
was to serve the main thing you got to
figure out what your main thing is I was
building an email list because you
should be so I used the email list to
support getting the YouTube channel even
bigger and then you know monetizing in
different ways cyber monday hey here's a
bunch of stuff I found in Amazon or
whatever so like ways to monetize so
support and that it was any additional
thing was in direct support of the main
thing what is your main thing y'all I
hope you got some value on a Friday
night off that hit the like button if
you did I want to follow up with some of
your questions and I want to remind you
that when it comes to figuring out this
YouTube thing you got a friend that can
help
and whether that's your on tech media
think marketing you know on YouTube with
free content I'm here to help but if you
want to accelerate yourself accelerate
your results in there and you would say
if you would say my main thing that I
get is like you to say man I see the
potential of YouTube cuz it's only
content it's the only platform where
your content lives forever it's a search
engine the reason I invested in YouTube
is because every video you upload is
like an employee you pay once but you
never have to pay again if it ranks so I
realize I needed leverage like
eventually a team can become leverage
because you if you're not working the
team member is and you're paying them
but if it hopefully is all producing
more money well that's leverage
investing in real estate that maybe pays
you cash flow rent well that's leverage
if you ever really want to succeed in
online business you have to understand
leverage the power of YouTube is a
filling content platform of your content
lives forever if you're trying to build
on Facebook well you got to keep going
friggin live you got to keep that
newsfeed going and nobody's looking at
your stuff from a week ago Instagram you
got to be doing everything I've got to
go live I got to post another fee post I
got to post another IG TV oh shoot I
took two weeks off because I've been
exhausting myself from over working on
all my blog and everything else and so
then I lose my results but when you do
YouTube right and you rank videos it
starts to gush for you it's a compound
effect that is why I saw the beauty of
YouTube I was doing the beauty of
YouTube for others so I went all-in on
YouTube and if you want to learn exactly
how I did it don't miss in terms of
revenue I explain the financial side on
this free class that ends tonight so I
encourage you to check that out idea to
income tips and I'm taking that down
tonight because that breaks down the
monetization strategy that I compounded
to reach financial freedom and then
scale an online business to accomplish
all my other dreams or what I mean is of
course not just building a business
around a lifestyle I have a dream to
create stuff like you maybe you have a
dream like man I want to write books I
want to record albums I want to make
music I want to fund my projects I want
to do
more stuff I want to start other
businesses I want to scale I want to do
more you can't do it all at once and you
are exhausting your endless energy by
running down in the bridge adding four
nails and five boards just to run all
the way back and then add five boards
and seven nails to the next one and
never really getting something completed
to profit let me know if you got an aha
during that yeah I can drop that link
ww idea to income dot tips I don't know
if that's gonna work on the Facebook
sidekicks train yard but that's what it
is
Glenn's like I was hoping for a quick
answer I got a 30-minute answer my man
Wow we went long on that so I hope that
added value y'all and Val that's so good
using social to support YouTube so many
burnout trying to create new content for
everything which grows nothing value
summed it up and it takes this is a I
don't want to swear on here but I got to
swear because it's a Friday night and
I'm feeling saucy we got to say the D
word man it takes discipline I don't
mean any curse I know nobody wants to
hear it nobody wants us to say the D
word it takes discipline to say man I'm
gonna go I'm gonna guard my focus I'm
gonna not do some projects and I'm gonna
stay disciplined to learn the skills to
post videos to master the platform to
level up my skills to compound because
the compound effect of doing the same
thing you know it's like starting a diet
and stopping your diet I worked out for
a week and then I stopped working out
and then I switched and then I stopped
for two weeks and we never get
consistent results because like Tony
said on the YouTube influence challenge
it's focused intensity over time and and
you only have so much energy you have
only have so much willpower you only
have so much creative focus you think
you're invincible man we're all we don't
have that much time and energy and when
we do
that's the power of essentialism they do
it like a chart up like you let's say
you only have 10 units of energy and
you'd put 3 here 2 here 1 here 6 here
and then you're out of energy but what
if you put 10 here and then you woke up
the next day and put 10 here and then
you woke up the next day and put 10 here
and obviously I'm preaching YouTube hard
but I'm saying you got a pic for you you
got a no it's your next rights like it
could be like get your book done because
when your books done and for sale and on
Amazon and on your website and the
audiobooks done you can't make sales you
can make money you can make profit so
now when you go do the other thing
you're able to do like get the online
course done and in love why are you
building to online courses at once why
don't you build one online course right
because what good is to unfinished
online courses like one finished online
course would be so much more powerful my
friends there is so many courses I want
to create there's so many books I want
to write there's there's like
motivational CDs I want to record no
joke like there's like I wake up every
day and even the think media team will
tell you this is why it's nice to have
people in your corner like we're even in
this community right now like hanging
out in the challenge group or hanging
out on my Facebook page or hanging out
thick market like we're in your corner
to help you say stop the madness
like I really hope this training this
can change your life and someone in your
corner that can challenge you with this
question right now and coaching and say
man what do you need to stop like what
do you need to quit and what do you need
to focus on so you can really get
momentum and get results I feel you Sean
everything has a season
Jessica says me too harsh but necessary
one at a time one at a time one at a
time
that's right that's right more jewelry I
love you and I'm and pick one pick one
and finish it get it going and finish it
but listen keep working
on it finish it next step fix it
finesse it improve it make sense people
get an online course I am guilty of this
as soon as I get it done I'm like phew
it's it's like kinda done let me go
create something else you gotta keep
focusing even on the thing much longer
let's go really big picture this is
where things are going on Friday I got
to land a plane but if you've been
enjoying the evening share this with
somebody who needs to see it and lightly
touch the heart button on Facebook and
the like button on YouTube you want to
know it's really hard in
entrepreneurship choosing a brand and
sticking with a brand while a lot of the
reason a lot of you are struggling on
YouTube is you can you can't even sit
with the brand for like a couple weeks
or a couple months to start what about
sticking with a brand for a couple years
or even a couple decades I might be kind
of big think for right now I'm thinking
a big bag like a little big and you can
pivot of course you can change but like
you know how long I've been talking
about cameras you think I ever get tired
about talking about cameras you think I
ever get like okay what else can I say
about a microphone like just press
freakin record to make a video and I
still get excited about cameras it's my
passion but this is I'm gonna cuss again
man discipline it's knowing man if I
built momentum and awareness here's what
I mean I see people with their Instagram
BIOS whatever their YouTube I oh I am a
social media expert next couple weeks
I am a fitness and nutrition coach four
months later I am a life coach two years
later I now AM an inner healing
specialist two years later I now am an
online WordPress but I'm like freaking
what do what do you do and by the time
you you you get to score it you also
think you need a pivot don't give up
before the breakthrough people get here
and they're like you know that business
work that bran didn't work my personal
brand didn't work let me go back and
build another one you got to stick with
something because when you stick with it
and see it through and then not only see
it through I've been doing take media
for ten years you don't think I've ever
thought about quitting or like wanting
to pivot or wanting to change or I
wanted to get bored I'm talking about
the D word there's a level of discipline
that just understands man if I can stay
focused and I can really get traction in
something and I can stick with it
eventually that thing will be like a
seed if it's a seed it's a dream at
first eventually grows into an oak tree
and eventually it provides shade and and
resource and support and strength for
other things that I want to do I'm kind
of reaching those days right now but
even right now I could exit this thing
kind of you know like go start working
on on other projects I want to do
because I'm like you I got a lot of
passion projects I think my strength is
a little bit of discipline and a
willingness to stick to it to stick it
out and to stick with a brand to even to
even believe this I've been doing thing
because I see people shift on YouTube
and please don't misunderstand me you
can pivot if you fall out of love with
something you can certainly change but
there's something about being able to
spark your own fire pivot spark you know
your your momentum your energy and stick
with something I see it a lot
I mean fatigue happens burnout happens
take a break take a vacation but stick
with something cuz eventually this is
how empires get built you know how did
Dave Ramsey become the debt free guy
because he's still talking about
personal finance if he was into 14
different things you know we wouldn't
even know him for anything like you
don't want to be a wandering generality
you want to be a meaningful specific and
being the camera and the YouTube guy is
not even my ultimate life destination
and dream but I'm still sticking with it
and even I'm talking to Benji we're
right in the next version of this by the
way it comes out 2021 talking to Benji
I'm like the friggin
I mean ship is sailing its terms of our
energy can we just talk about something
else what else we're gonna say about
YouTube discipline double down and keep
focusing because this also might sound
funny but this is sort of like a weird
Friday night Mentor coaching set ship
session where I'm also just expounding
on my thoughts and how I think about
brands and building I also feel like I
haven't started and I say that with
respect because obviously this book sold
40,000 copies and a million subscribers
but like nobody knows me if that makes
sense
like nobody like I'm not a celebrity
just an average guy like it's a little
weird every once in a while there's like
a grocery store someone will come up and
tap me like are you on YouTube like a
grocery tell or the other day and
airports but you get I mean like there's
a difference between Kevin Hart and
Shawn channel like ain't nobody know who
Sean Cannell is fair so to really build
momentum in a in something there's
something about sticking with it now you
might say Shawn how do I figure it out
we don't got time to go into that that's
why we have resources and coaching with
like clarity that's why you want to
experiment a lot that's why you know
eventually you want to find your thing
that's that you might need to try a few
different things to find your thing but
when you really build power is when you
really like if you want to check out a
book check out the one thing because
that's where you really build power it's
where you really build influence and
it's where you really breakthrough
getting known for one thing because then
one thing can lead to everything and so
to a point now I can fund anything like
projects like things I want to do I can
risk and take experiments on stuff but
you shouldn't be doing that when you
need to build your one thing you don't
even have the resource to do the one
thing let me know if you got value out
of this let me know if this is helping
and here's what I would say do next
because I'm gonna be chilling with my
wife here soon and eating dinner if
you're ready to learn you're ready to
dive in there's only five hours left so
I'd say go watch this idea to income dot
tips and you can keep learning and get
clear on how to specifically build a
way of monetization on YouTube quickly I
share some stuff that's why I'm not
leaving it up because this is some
information that is just in our premium
programs and as a reminder you know that
YouTube influence bundle is ending
really soon as well so Donald the
challenge was the AHA I appreciate that
Evelyn thanks so much and Daniel I
appreciate that and and I respect I mean
trust me I understand I am known but
like you get what I mean like not that I
ultimately want to be unlike Ellen but
maybe I'll be in Ellen in five years
maybe if I pivot but probably if I stick
with something soon I'm like you really
become known when you've been doing
something for five years ten years
fifteen years and you stick with it and
you built up such a library of work and
that's what I want to encourage you to
do the dinner burn last night with the
fire alarm by the way if you watch this
you're gonna see a funny moment on this
where the fire alarm goes off come on
life is life
no it was just a little bit of it was
pizza you know a little bit of cheese
because you just put the pizza on the
rack and a little cheese falls down a
little smoke comes out started the fire
alarm your mid training mid livestream
and all of a sudden you know things are
getting crazy and you know going up so
can somebody give me a favor can
somebody type idea to income tips ww
idea to income dot tips on Facebook I
see if I don't think it's working in
either group or both groups so drop that
for me that's how you're gonna get to
this page so if you can just drop that
link for me I did post it but I don't
think it's making too - both to both
groups so do me a favor if you could do
that on on YouTube - that'd be huge idea
- income tips awesome Pamela thanks so
much for being a part of it and thanks
for hosting and helping me excited for
dinner excited to hang out with wifey 23
weeks pregnant today Gela
welcome to the VR a fam really
appreciates you and grateful you're here
hey let's hang out tomorrow we are gonna
be hanging out at
if you're in VRA dawn welcome to the
famine thanks for jumping in at another
level and let's build it's time to build
and we're gonna drop some serious value
on you plus everything else
Argentina says can you say the name of
the program again so the program is
called the YouTube influence I don't
even know I don't know anything at this
point if I think media bundle com if
somebody could do me a favor and drop
that I'm just out here solo floating on
the ocean hope to make it home soon
thank media bundle calm and and what it
is is it's called the YouTube influence
course and coaching bundle and so that's
the name of the course Argentina and you
can check out all the details everything
is ending tonight and so definitely
check that out and what you're gonna see
right you see the countdown and this is
this is the craziest thing we've ever
done you know as far as with our all the
coaching that's in it the camera
confidence is a new course Heather and I
are gonna be recording together you're
gonna master this YouTube framework you
get a lot of extra bonuses like our
social media training like our YouTube
live influence system and our whole
other course the YouTube hybrid growth
blueprint there's some videos to watch
there's a lot of coaching involved and
tomorrow morning we're doing a special
Heather and Mel are gonna be there and
we're doing a special channel reviews
giveaways just for everybody that's been
joining the fam and so if you're
interested in checking that out you know
I think I actually without Heather and
Mel here I don't know how to do anything
but I think I got a URL for it that I
can put on the screen just for anybody
who has any questions about that so take
action soon definitely watch the free
class that's only up for a few more
hours and then definitely check out
think media bundle com
screenshot that check out the webpage
you'll see all the details even if you
have any questions about it I want to
say thanks to everybody who is a part of
the challenge this week thank you to
everybody that has been building that
our YouTube channels taking action punch
in fear in the face and then yeah if
you're watching I think marketing
there's a link in the description over
to that free class that's up until the
evening Jim bomb a Mia appreciates you
thanks for checking it out hey let's get
focused and I'm excited to check back on
the live chat cuz Cassandra says what
would I do over if I was going to do it
differently
I would have got focused sooner I would
have it didn't really exist I wish I
would have had the YouTube influence
bundle I would have got connected to a
community that could have helped me see
my blind spots I would have gotten too
connected to a community that could just
actually tell me what to do step by step
because I was experimenting and
wandering in the desert I was working on
my Sean Cannell channel I should have
been working on my thick media channel
and I was kind of working on my my
freelance channel and I was dividing my
focus I would have got focused sooner
and I would have because once I did and
I was forced to get focused because I
lost my freelance clients in October
2015
this is there's two ways to change your
life you either and most people don't
change unless they experience pain and
that's what happened to me do two
biggest times my life change was when I
experienced pain was when my wife almost
died and that got me going in the right
direction and then it's when my clients
all fired me in three weeks time and
that got me okay now I've been dabbling
on YouTube and and kind of not confident
to lean in so now I'm gonna lean in most
of the time that's when we change is
when desperation hits us it's that
wake-up call it's that rock bottom
moment let me know if anybody can relate
it's that it's that someone passes away
it's that all the sudden you see
different
it's you lose a family member it's you
lose a job it's a pandemic hits and you
start to really evaluate what's much
more difficult is to disrupt your own
life and is to disrupt your own life and
say I'm gonna get myself uncomfortable
I'm gonna make some level of sacrifice
I'm going to shift my own life because
we don't want to do that
I'll be honest October 2015 in 2015 the
year I'm making sixty sixty thousand
dollars from freelance clients living in
Vegas cost of living is pretty cheap I
was like were rich and I was not in a
state of like leaning in until I got
disrupted makes sense so it was when God
kicked me off the cliff because at some
point in entrepreneurship you have to
jump off but then I called David gold
see he's like dude you got to go all-in
so that's what I would do different I
would have gone all-in with more focus
sooner and not kind of just dabbled
around because I didn't I didn't have
this training that I just gave you you
know and so I would have just leaned
all-in and I would have got cuz in
hindsight this wouldn't have taken that
long if I didn't divide my energy here's
what here's what I did I wrote I wrote
an e-book called get notice I have an
unfinished at multiple unfinished books
I have multiple URLs is anybody a
GoDaddy URL junkie like me I bought like
Church media tool kit.com I was gonna
like build out this ebook and I've
thought about it I started outlining it
and then I bought like a couple other
Church media ones and I again I have
like all these unfinished half written
ebooks
I was like I'm gonna start building up I
need like a free gift to give away to
build an email list so I was building up
all these things what I would have done
if I wouldn't freaking got focused
identified my profit path and built on
that thing and and then once I did that
I could have jumped and made steps
further you know I don't regret my
journey but I certainly could have got
there quicker and and so so creative
says Cova nineteen's a blessing in
disguise I agree the
you could take the good out of the
season to say has this disrupted my life
caused me to rethink about what I'm
gonna build
cause me to you know reevaluate and if
it has that's a blessing because it
could be the much-needed life
interruption that just makes you think
okay what am i building what are my
priorities what should I build next and
what resources and what community do I
need on the journey and so you know if
now is the right time for you and
YouTube is your decision
check out the think media bundle comm
because that'll just help you go further
faster if that's not right for you cool
stay connected and keep building stay
connected this community or you might
say you know what I need to get my
freelance business like you might your
thing might be different that's respect
it's like whatever it is go all in and
and don't do too many things all at once
hey if you got value on this stream
tonight or today if you catch the replay
I don't think I'll probably leave it up
but who knows that class is coming down
soon and so I think that that's at idea
two income got tips that's in the
description of the YouTube page YouTube
page and type all in if you're going all
in and whatever your project is right
now and thanks so much for hanging out
on this stream tonight I hope you got
some value donald see tomorrow at 9:00
at the party and yeah yeah yeah Matthew
said don't worry I'll tell your boy
Brady at her church tools that's right
Matthew Brady carried the torch he used
to watch think media allah brady so much
and i agree he he's killing it I love
what he's doing and so uh Wendy says I
agree I need to do what my hoodie says
pray blog make money repeat bang that's
beautiful actually and get that thing
get your trickle to a river to a gusher
to a flood and then fund those other
projects Facebook user sorry I know
sometimes
logged-in I bought so many domains
exactly as entrepreneurs you got fifty
five domains for the fifty-five books
YouTube channels courses you want to
post you know and so appreciate you
check everything out thanks for being
here
check out that web class cuz it's only
up for a few more hours and in the
meantime keep crushing it keep smashing
it and we will talk soon peace